good evening  the Jean Hersholt award is given not for  just what you have done but for what you  are it is not merely presented for  achievement but for the manner in which  these achievements were made for giving  unstintingly of his time his efforts his  intelligence and his substance to the  betterment of the lot of his fellow men  in philanthropic endeavors in culture  and in humanity that is why we are proud  to honor him tonight mr. Lew Wasserman  I'm gonna need some direction  thank you hitching my sincere thanks to  the Board of Governors of the Academy I  would also like to like to thank my wife  Edie Jule Styne and all of my associates  at MCA for permitting me to devote the  time to the work that the Academy  thought was worthy of this deeply  appreciated honor thank you and good  night Carol